okay thank you Steve and thank you very
much to inviting me to come and give a
talk in this seminar series I have to
admit I had a sneaky look on the website
week week or so ago and actually
listened to one or two of the lectures
so I realized I've brought a lot to live
up to anyway so as you heard the focus
of my talk today is going to be on the
prefrontal circuits underlying anxiety
and anhedonia and we're interested not
only in establishing the circuits that
underlie the regulation of both positive
and negative emotion but also trying to
understand how current therapists use
for treating anxiety depression actually
what though those neurobiological
mechanisms are I know from having seen
the talks you've already had at this
series that you've heard a lot about the
problems that kind of factors that
currently are making progress very slow
in understanding the etiology of
psychiatric disorders as well as their
treatments but I'm not going to dwell
too much on that today but I'm just
going to give you my take on it with
respect to anxiety and depression but
particularly with respect to depression
and I think there's some sort of three
key things to realize the first is to
patients can be diagnosed with
depression and have no overlapping
symptoms even if two patients have the
same symptoms the psychological and
neurobiological underpinnings of that
symptom may well differ and that's
primarily because the clinical symptoms
of anxiety and depression have been
poorly characterized up until now and
finally even when treatments do work we
don't actually know how they work and
therefore we can't predict which
treatments are going to work best in
which patients which means patients are
still being used as guinea pigs for
trying to work out which twelve is going
to be best effective for that particular
individual so for all those reasons as
you I know of heard from other speakers
in this series we need better
stratification of anxiety and depression
and we need to be able to develop
personalized treatment strategies
we have here a relatively simplified
schematic of the brain and various
structures in the brain that are we know
are already associated with emotion and
I start looking today by a lot of
pointer electronic pointer anyway thank
you
we know subcortical e that structures
such as the amygdala and the bed knew to
destroy terminalis are key components of
the subcortical emotion system both in
the acquisition and expression of
emotion and that through their
projections out to downstream structures
in the basal in the brainstem in the
hypothalamus and up into the stratum are
involved ultimately in orchestrating the
expression of our emotions and we've
gleaned a lot of information about this
circuit from studies in rodents but we
have far less of an understanding about
the cortical regulation modulation of
this downstream circuitry in particular
the prefrontal cortex shown here in pale
blue we know that some people are more
or less likely to go on and develop a
psychiatric disorder and one of the
factors that makes you more vulnerable
to developing anxiety disorder is in
fact anxiety itself anxiety is an
adaptive emotional state it's important
for us to be able to avoid negative
stimuli in the environment but if it's
chronically engaged it can become
pathological and ultimately go on to
lead to a variety of different anxiety
disorders or indeed depression but what
makes you or I either low or high
anxious as a behavioral trait primarily
it's a combination of the genes we were
born with and environmental experiences
as we were growing up and together these
interact to ultimately affect the
development of these circuits which
ultimately may lead to cognitive and
behavioral dysregulation later on in
life and ultimately make us more or less
vulnerable to developing a psychiatric
disorder I've I said the most important
regulation of this circuitry sub
cortical circuitry is the over line
quartets in particular the prefrontal
cortex and that's why I'm wanting to do
studies in primates because by far the
most complex cortical structure is found
in monkeys and humans and this can be
seen in this next picture which just
shows you how much cortex or how much of
the brain is given over to the cortex in
rodents right up to humans in rodents
twenty-eight percent of the brain is
cortex which is where the highest
processing of information is going on in
the brain in humans it's 80 percent and
if we turn and look at monkeys new world
monkeys the marmoset that I work on and
old world monkeys the rhesus monkey you
can see that again of the brain sixty or
seventy percent of it is made up of
cortex so that straightaway shows you
why within an overall experimental
strategy we need monkeys at the center
of it and if we look specifically at the
prefrontal cortex which we know is very
important in regulating emotion this
shows you the prefrontal cortex in
humans in rhesus monkeys and in marmoset
and what you can see overall here is
that the structure looks rather similar
based on overall structural analysis
there are a number of different regions
within the human and monkey prefrontal
cortex ranging from areas 9 through 10
11 12 13 and 14 and then anterior
cingulate regions 24 25 and 32 and
they're all well the similar across the
species whereas what you can see is when
you turn to the rat whilst it has a very
distinct population we haven't as yet we
don't know how these areas map onto the
present if there are a present areas in
primate for all these reasons then I've
chosen to work on a primate and I've
chosen to work on the mama deck and in
our lab we have approximately four
different experimental strategies the
first is to actually manipulate various
structures within the prefrontal cortex
and related areas in order to establish
cause and effect brain imaging has told
it a lot about what's going on in
patients with various psychiatric
disorders but ultimately we can't
establish cause and effect we can't
determine whether particular areas of
altered activity in the brain in a human
patient actually causes a particular
symptom even if we look at the brain
changes in brain before the disorder
comes on you still can't establish
causality for example some of the
changes you see may in fact be due to
compensate and effects so the brain may
be compensating for some of these
changes so in order to address that
issue you have to turn to experimental
studies in animals so that's why in the
marmoset we look to see for example if
specific alterations and activity in one
or other of these prefrontal regions can
actually cause specific deficits that
look like anxiety or anhedonia combining
with our manipulation studies we've
started to use micro pet in particular
fluid eopsi glucose which allows us to
measure activity in the rest of the
brain when we make these manipulations
that will allow us then to see what is
the knock-on effects not only of our
particular manipulation on behavior but
also what's happened to the rest of the
brain as a consequence of that
manipulation also in a lab we are
starting to study the various traits
behavioral traits that we know makes you
more vulnerable to developing
psychiatric disorder so we originally
now start the look started looking at
trait anxiety in Varma debts they show a
massive range of differences in their
anxiety levels and by studying them in a
breeding colony were able to start
looking at the neurobiological
mechanisms that may underlie how anxious
you are as a trait and then finally more
recently we started to look at genetic
risk factors and we focused on the
serotonin transporter polymorphism which
has been implicated in developing
anxiety and depression in humans and we
found that whilst we don't have the
exact same polymorphism in Marmaduke's
there is a very similar one that seems
to have very similar functional
consequences but what we can do in the
marmoset was of course it can't do in
humans is it actually study the
underlying neurobiological and
importantly the molecular and cellular
mechanisms that explain how a change in
a genetic polymorphism can ultimately
have such an impact on behavior which it
does in the marmoset however for today's
talk I'm going to focus primarily on
these two strategies with respect to
anhedonia and anxiety and so I will
first tell you about some recent work
we've been doing looking at the auto
frontal and ventral lateral prefrontal
regions in the mama deck and their
interactions with downstream structures
including the amygdala and hippocampus
with respect to anxiety and negative
bias and then second half of my talk I
will focus on anhedonia the loss of
pleasure and look at areas of the brain
in particular causal sub genial
prefrontal cortex area 25 and its
interaction with the dorsal anterior
cingulate cortex and the insula and some
of you who are at professor Atkins talk
a couple of months ago may remember that
he actually showed you how important
anxiety and anhedonia may well be with
respect to biomarkers of depression but
not on their own but in relationship
with altered structural and functional
changes in the brain and how together
anxiety and depression and their
associated changes in the brain may in
fact allow one to separate out different
components of depression in different
patients in all the studies I'm going to
show you there are some important
principles that we're always trying to
which we always try to use to drive our
research and that's always looking to
bridge translational gaps that we
perceive are already existing in the
literature the first one I've already
mentioned is with respect to the
prefrontal cortex as studies in rodents
compared to humans we need the monkey to
bridge that gap however there's some
other gaps we've also tried to breach in
the studies we've designed the first is
with respect to emotion per se because
how you measure emotion differs quite
markedly between studies in rodents and
studies in humans in rodents the primary
measure of negative emotion tends to be
a freezing response to a stimulus that
they've learned is associated stay with
shock where's in humans even though they
may use the same behavioral test the
same conditioned fear paradigm they
don't measure behavior they don't
measure freezing because humans that
refreeze in that kind of situation they
measure autonomic activity they measure
skin conductance responses or they
measure heart rate they measure
physiological responses but ultimately
an emotional state is a product of the
interaction between our physiological
changes the behavioral changes and
subjectivity that's altogether produces
that emotional state so if you want a
measure emotion I strongly believe you
need to be able to measure more than one
aspect of the emotional output so in the
marmosets many of the study flights will
show you what we do is we measure their
cardiovascular activity alongside their
behavior and to do that in a one-off
surgical operation we implant a probe
into the descending aorta zamana debt
which allows us subsequently to measure
their behavior in freely moving animals
in the test apparatus wirelessly so we
can measure both behavior and
cardiovascular activity again bridging
that gap and finally the third gap we
want to bridge isn't between rodents and
humans it's actually between rodents and
humans and other studies in monkeys
because both rodents and humans when
study negative emotion tend to use
Pavlovian
missioned paradigms where animals learn
and acquire a particular condition fear
response to a stimulus that they've
learned it associated with something
nasty whereas some of the earliest
studies done in in the rhesus monkeys
used paradigms such as innate fear their
innate fear responses to a snake or
anxiety responses for example to our
unknown human where you don't know the
humans going to perhaps give you food or
try and catch you so it's an uncertainty
and anxiety associated with it but in
fact we know to a certain extent that
these kinds of different innate fears or
anxiety may not completely work to the
same circuit as these learned fears and
therefore in the marmosets in fact what
we've designed is not only we don't only
your cat responses to snakes and human
intruders so we come back we can
translate our findings to what's already
been gone it's gone forward in the
rhesus monkeys but we can also translate
our findings into the make sense them in
respect to rodent and human data because
we've developed fear conditioning times
in the monitors and the two areas we
first decided to look at with respect to
anxiety with a ventral prefrontal cortex
the orbitofrontal cortex and the ventral
lateral prefrontal cortex because these
regions have been shown to be a sho
altered structural and functional
activity in depression as well as a
whole range of anxiety disorders so they
look like a good starting point and
these were areas that hadn't
traditionally been looked at at all in
the road literature in Part B could is
not clear rodent prefrontal cortex has a
ventral lateral region and up until more
recently no one has really looked at the
orbitofrontal cortex with respect to
rodents and fear conditioning so the
original paradigm we developed this have
lo the entire time in the marmots we use
aversive loud noise as our unconditioned
stimulus rather than foot shock you
don't want to shock the monkeys but
aversive loud noise has been very you
have been used very successfully in
human studies and so animals are
presented with one of two cues which
come on for 20 seconds to sounds pass a
tone and white noise
and after that 20 seconds after one of
them the aversive loud noise which is
punctate between point three point five
of a second a hundred twenty decibel
found and they learn that one of the Q's
Davis sound the white noise is
associated with a burst of loud noise
and we compared their cardiovascular and
behavioral changes within the spheres
periods compared to the twenty second
baseline period so within a single
Pavlovian conditioning session they'll
receive up to 60 s pluses the ones are
associated with a burst of loud noise
and fix what we call c s- DS which
aren't associated with anything aversive
and this shows you the conditions
cardiovascular changes that you see this
is change from baseline
so during baseline it's at zero then
when the c s- comes on which predicts
nothing there is no change in the
college of estuary activity this is
heart rate whereas when spheres plus
comes on that ultimately predicts the
aversive loud noise you see this rise in
heart rate so this is your conditioned
cardiovascular response and alongside
that behaviorally they show this
enhanced vigilant scanning response
during this year's class but not fear -
and this has published quite a long time
ago now and I'm not going to go into the
details of this study but just to tell
you that what we found was that when we
lesions either the orbitofrontal cortex
or the ventral lateral prefrontal cortex
and we did this using selective exciti
toxins that literally destroy the cell
bodies within these two distinct regions
we found that if the animals had already
learnt this condition discrimination
prior surgery post surgery the lesions
had no impact on the overall expression
of their condition fear responses if
they'd learnt them prior to the lesion
what we did find however is that if we
then change the relationship between the
stares class and the adversity of loud
noise so things weren't quite as
predictable anymore where is the control
animals tended to show their condition
cardiovascular behavior responses to
follow and track the various changes
that was going on in the environment the
lesion danimals didn't they showed very
rigid conditioned fear responses based
on what they'd originally learned and
they didn't really adapt them to changes
in the environment we then went on to
look at the effects of these same
lesions in the same animals on the two
tests that have been traditionally used
in rhesus monkey studies responding to a
human intruder where an unknown person
comes into the room and stares at them
in the in one of the quadrants of their
home cage for two minutes that's enough
to make them slightly anxious or we put
a rubber snake into the home cage for a
couple of minutes and so this is the two
paradigms you get a whole repertoire of
behaviors associated with these two
traits
obviously they depending on how anxious
they are they go towards the back of the
cage they may may not move around so
much they show a bit of head bobbing but
some of the specific behaviors change
depending on whether it's a human there
or snake and they also make some calls
so what we did is having made all these
measurements we threw them all into a
principal component analysis and that
told us that though it appeared to be
two main components where certain
behaviors tended to cluster with one
another and the way I want to focus on
is the emotionality component because
the behaviors that clustered on this
component were locomotion whether they
were still or not how far they were from
the front of the cage so that if they
were at the back of the cage and not
moving much and doing quite a bit of
head bobbing that was a very high score
on that component and that's what's
suggested to us - that basically
reflected their overall emotionality and
so we looked at the effects of making
these two lesions the orbitofrontal and
ventral lateral PFC lesion on these
measures and what I'm showing you here
is performance on the snake test on the
y-axis and performance on the human
intruder test on the x-axis and all the
braid dots are individual animals that
we've tested in the colony and this show
you the huge range of trait anxiety in
these animals so there are some animals
that show really high anxiety responses
to snakes and human intruders and
another range of animals that actually
don't show much fun exam
response at all in fact they're more
interested as opposed to being scared so
this is the overall range in the colony
it just so happens that the animals in
our lesion study shown here in blue
before the lesion were relatively low
anxious now our reasons to that if
anyone's interested afterwards but they
were low anxious however having had that
lesion of either the orbitofrontal
cortex in orange or the ventral lateral
prefrontal lesion in green there are
anxiety scores there emotionality
measure on both the snake test and the
human intuitive test goes up though
there you can see it's going up on the
snake test axis and it's going up along
this way on the but on the x axis so
they're showing enhanced anxiety but if
you look at them in relation to the
entire colony they're not religiously
anxious they're not so super anxious
that they look like no other animal ever
existed they're just showing more
anxiety than they did previously but
clearly there are animals in the colony
that are still much more anxious than
they are and they don't have to our
knowledge a particular brain lesion but
they may well have Gibbs regulation in
some of these areas so overall then what
I've shown you from this first study is
that both lesions of this orbitofrontal
cortex and lesions of this ventral
lateral prefrontal cortex produce rather
similar effects heightened fear
conditioning
make it more rigid heightened anxiety
and heightened innate fear responses but
we know these two areas are not doing
the same thing these two areas are very
distinct have very distinct cognitive
function so our next question was what
exactly are the distinct cognitive
functions but of contributing to what
ostensibly looks like a very similar
syndrome of being more anxious and shown
while the inflexible fear responses so
to do that we moved on to a more
sophisticated cognitive paradigm and we
chose to look at what we'd call a
decision-making paradigm but it's often
called an approach avoidance
so in this task we initially trained
mama debts to respond to two stimuli on
the screen which are associated with
gaining access to reward and this is the
work of Hannah Clark in the laboratory
and responding on both of these stimuli
give you reward on some kind of variable
interval schedule so what that means is
that after a certain variable delay the
first response on the screen afterwards
is you reward so what the animal should
do on this task is respond relatively
sustained and constantly but it never
quite knows when the next rewards coming
and also switch they're responding
between the two stimuli because they'll
maximize their responses by performing
on both stimuli and that's the reward
only condition but occasionally we
introduce punishment but we only
introduce punishment on one side in this
case on the left so on that particular
session which we only perhaps run once a
week they'll come in they'll ways be
responding away for reward and suddenly
a response on that side punishment
occurs the punishment is that aversive
loud noise I've described already so if
they don't like the punishment and they
find it really aversive they can avoid
it by just doing all the responding on
the other side they won't get the
maximum amount of reward but they will
still get quite a lot of reward by doing
so but in fact what we found was our
moms it actually found the reward too
nice and so they carried on responding
even on the side where they got the
punishment and this is the sound that
previously I've shown you produces quite
strong Pavlovian conditioned fear
responses but nevertheless as soon as
you put it into a situated lis mild and
when you put it into a situation where
now they're getting reward you find
actually they'll carry on responding but
the question arises what happens if we
inactivate those two regions of
prefrontal cortex this time rather than
doing lesions we've now moved on and
instead we cannulate these regions
there's the ventral lateral cannulation
and the orbital cannulation and we
infuse down there a cocktail of gather a
and gab
the agonist drugs but act to excite the
gatherers you can hear between two
neurons which effectively dampen the
activity in that area but only
temporarily so on any one session we
might suddenly one day inactivate that
area and it will last for 20-30 minutes
and then we can look at the effects of
that inactivation temporarily on their
performance in this task there is no
effect on overall responding for reward
it's in activating either these regions
makes no difference to the animal but we
did find an interesting effect when we
look at the effect of in activating
either these regions on this probe tasks
on this probe session this first graph
shows you what happens when we in
activate the ventral lateral prefrontal
cortex this shows you a bias of
responding so if you're responding at
100% you're equally responding on both
sides of the screen you don't care and
this shows you the change from say line
so this shows you that anything above
the line means that you're actually
showing a bias away from the punishment
and this is different from the control
thus a line condition when we just
injected say line which has no effect so
what you can see when we inactivate
eventer lateral prefrontal cortex they
show this strong bias away from the
punish side which they didn't do under
normal say line condition though it was
this the ventral lateral prefrontal
cortex had enhanced the punishment in
some way such that they wanted to avoid
it a lot more now in contrast when we
inactivated the orbitofrontal cortex on
the day that we did the inactivation
when they received punishment there was
absolutely no affect the animals carried
on responding normally the famous a line
but what we found was this next day
you're probably wondering why the next
day was there this is why the next day
is there on the graph because on the
next day when there is no punishment
there is no infusion into the brain this
is just next day but suddenly the animal
to the orbital in frontal inactivation
from that day show am I
spire two ways in the punishment but
there OSC is not being inactivated that
day there is no punishment that day so
the only reason they must be avoiding
the punished side from yesterday is
because somehow they remember the
punishment and remembering that
punishment it must be quite a strong
punishment memory to make them avoid it
so it appears that the ofc increases
punishment avoidance but not on the day
when you've inactivated us seed on the
next day there's no effect driver these
manipulations on overall responding in
the task so our next question was if
there somehow got this strong memory of
punishment from the day before when
you've been activated the OSC first of
all what's driving is punishment memory
two obvious structures are the amygdala
and the hippocampus those subcortical
structures that we know are critical for
learning about punishment in the
environment and showing expression of
punishment so Hannah went on and kept
cannulated in the same animals the
amygdala and hippocampus and then we
asked the following question we know
that if we inactivate the OSC this day
when they're receiving punishment doses
enhanced punishment buys the next day
where's that punishment buyers coming
from where's the memory coming from that
drives that bias if it's coming from the
amygdala if we inactivate the amygdala
on that next day we should block the
bias and that's exactly what we found so
that now if we in activate the amygdala
on that next day having an activated
view of see the day before during
punishment they no longer show the
biased they also no longer show the bias
if you inactivate the hippocampus and
also they no longer show the bhai's if
you disconnect the amygdala from the
hippocampus so in all in all it would
appear that the amygdala and hippocampus
downstream are important circuit for
expressing that strong punishment memory
the next day
but what this really is interesting is
it shows you that the orbitofrontal
cortex when it's normally online even
though it's not needed to avoid
punishment on the day nevertheless it is
learning about what's going on in on
that day and it's actually impacting on
what's learnt what's laid down in
structures such as for example the
amygdala the hippocampus so it's
affecting our overall perception of the
punishment on that day such that the
following day when we haven't had the
OFC online the amygdala potentially is
is have got a stronger punishment memory
than otherwise it should have so the OSC
appears to be modulating what we lay
down in terms of our memories about
punishment of course we're now going on
to do studies to allow us to explore
that in more detail for example we want
to now address the question w
orbitofrontal cortex need to talk to the
amygdala and all the hippocampus on the
day of the punishment in order to
influence the laying down of the
memories is that memory being laid down
differently in the amygdala the
hippocampus on the day all we've shown
so far is the imagined hippocampus is
important for the expression of that
memory the next day not necessarily the
actual where the memory is stored so in
summary then what I've shown you from
these two studies is that the
orbitofrontal cortex has a rather
distinct pattern of deficits on this
task to the ventral lateral prefrontal
cortex damage for how to interpret ly
well if we think about what we know
about the ante orbitofrontal cortex in
general we we've got some wonderful
studies that been done in both rodents
from Jeffery sure and bounds labs from
Betsy Murray's in monkeys that tell us
that the orbitofrontal cortex is very
important for learning about and
updating information about rewards and
punishments and environment for learning
to predict punishments and rewards and
particularly in updating that
information as the environment
constantly changes if you can't do that
but you inactivate the orbitofrontal
cortex what what happens is that you
become uncertain because you can't quite
predict what nerves going on in this
changing environment
if you become uncertain that makes you
more anxious because being on
certain is anxiety-provoking so we would
argue the reason you have a general
anxiety affects with damage to the altar
orbitofrontal cortex is because you've
knocked out your systems that's good at
tracking the changing punishment and
reward in the environment and that makes
you makes things uncertain and therefore
makes you anxious what about the ventral
lateral prefrontal cortex we showed many
years ago now that this structure the
ventral lateral region was really
important for attentional control
function we showed the diffusion this
area you impair the ability of an animal
to switch their attention from one
dimension of the world to another so how
do we think about that in terms of
anxiety why should it induce anxiety
well one hypothesis that we propose is
the following when that animal is in the
apparatus receiving its reward if
suddenly a burst of loud noise happens
that's a really salient event nasty
things are salient so you suddenly find
your attention dragging to that verse
sigmoid but in this context the
decision-making task you need to then
draw yourself back to the entire to the
context the reward you're receiving to
ultimately make a decision do I want to
carry on responding for reward
regardless of this punishment or
actually is this punishment so bad and
reward not that good
but I'm actually going to start trying
to avoid it in order to do that you have
to switch your attention back from that
very salient stimulus and I would argue
that one reason why they may have a
problem in doing that is because the
ventral lateral prefrontal cortex is
important for switching attention and if
you can't switch your attention because
you've been activated that very region
that normally allows you to do it then
you find yourself stop paying attention
to the diversity of loud noise and you
can't switch out can switch back from it
and or any of us if we end up spend all
our time paying attention to something
nasty we will become anxious so one
proposal then is these two regions are
producing anxiety but for two very
different reasons one because I have a
problem - switching attention the other
two have a problem updating and tracking
punch
award in the environment which means if
you take a patient with anxiety they may
have a disruption in one or other of
these circuits but you're going to treat
them differently there may be different
newer chemical drugs that we could use
to differentially affect activity in
either of these circuits and there
obviously is probably cognitive
behavioral therapies that you'd use
differently to help someone who has a
problem updating versus someone you have
a problem shifting attention so this is
why it's really critically important to
understand the underlying neural
circuits for what produces what sense we
looked like the same overall effect of
increased anxiety finally we went on to
ask one more question with this circuit
and that was although these two areas
are performing different functions do
they act and converge on the same
downstream emotional circuits or do they
operate in parallel and to answer that
question return to my prepared and two
fluid optic glucose fluid eopsi glucose
gets taken up by cells in the brain that
are very active but dropsy glucose can't
be broken down so to form energy and so
it stays in the cell and accumulates and
so it's a proxy marker of activity in
the brain and it was used a lot before
function imaging came on the scene in
human studies and it's still being used
a lot for example in side of depression
so we use fluid eopsi glucose to look to
see what changes are going on downstream
in the brain when we make these
manipulations in your frontal and
ventral after prefrontal cortex so
design is complicated because we wanted
to maximize the power of the design so
we had a unilateral lesion model because
we know that primarily orbital frontal
cortex on one side talks to downstream
structures on the same side there's very
little crossover we've got that from our
own mama deck tracing studies so we did
unilateral lesions of either the
orbitofrontal cortex or the ventral
lateral prefrontal cortex we've gone
back to lesions now it's cell body
lesions in separate groups of animals
after they would receive the leaves we
waited three months and then we'd form
three
scans the first scan they were given the
SDG and then for half an hour you have
you put them into a behavioral test
situation and the situation put them in
with fear induction they were put into
the test apparatus where they saw a
rubber snake and the lights went out and
that made them rather anxious half an
hour later at the end of that period you
Anissa ties the animal put them in the
PET scanner and look to see which brain
areas were most active during that
period as measured by the uptake of ftg
we then waited 10 days during that
period we have [ __ ] rated them to that
test apparatus so they went in the test
apparatus every day after that for half
an hour but every other day there was
never a doc and as never darkness there
was never a snake they got used to it
actually it's a relatively safe
environment and then after that ten days
we gave them the SDG bolus again they
went back into that now safe environment
and then half an hour later nothing
happened in that environment the light
was on they've got a bit bored probably
fell asleep a little bit but then the
end of that period they were scanned and
we looked at activity again and then
finally again to help strengthen the
power of our design we did a replication
of the fear induction where we now put
them in a different apparatus
after the third FDG injection and this
time there was a snake again and there
was darkness and we look to see what
areas of the brain first of all on the
intact side were differentially
sensitive to these two conditions fear
versus safety and not surprisingly the
amygdala lit up so what this means is
the activity here there was FDG uptake
in this area far greater in the fear
condition comport to fair conditions
compared to the safety condition so if
you like the amygdala knew whether it
was in a fearful condition or safety
conditions based on the amount of
activity that the the area was showing
and the amount of SPG's are taken up
that's on the intact side but what about
the lesions hemisphere where the emitter
is perfectly intact but there is now in
some animal
no orbitofrontal cortex and in other
animals noventa lateral prefrontal
cortex if you compare steer - safety in
those conditions there is no difference
in FD up FD g uptake in the amygdala
between fear and safety on the lesion
hemisphere but if you look at exactly
what the levels were you find that the
reason there is no difference is because
FD g uptake during safety was as great
as it was during the fear so the
amygdala was unable to know the
difference between fear and safety it's
assumed it was all fearful that either
in an animal which had no orbitofrontal
cortex on that side or in an animal
which had noventa lateral prefrontal
cortex so in both cases you see this
change in activity in the amygdala and
this just shows you the story in more
detail because the in fact is not just
in the amygdala the area we found that
shows this differential activity - fear
versus safety included the dorsal
amygdala but it also interact to the
anterior insula and that's on the intact
side and like I said that difference was
not seen on the lesion side and if you
look specifically that's the amygdala
into the cluster that we got from the
box for based analysis showing more FDG
uptake during spheres less in safety and
back up in fear if you look at purely
the amygdala component of that cluster
you see the same pattern if you look at
the insula component of that cluster you
see the same patterns in the intact side
and like I said in a lesion side I
haven't got the graph to show you but
you basically it's a flat line across
but it's high in all the conditions so
in summary then it appears these two
separate pathways nevertheless are
converging on downstream structures
include an immigrant insula in order to
regulate our emotional responses
normally to change in the context of the
environment but without those areas of
course the amygdala suddenly becomes
blind in a way to the various contextual
situations you're in where you're
normally expected to behave differently
I'm now going to change back a little
bit and move on to the other circuit
we've been looking at with respect to
anhedonia anna doe gives a lot of
pleasure and we know from studies and
depression that one of the areas that
shows marked change in activity in
depressed subject if this region the
ventromedial prefrontal cortex I'm using
Michael Petrie disease fighter octatonic
analysis of the area and variety of
changes have been shown Helen maybug has
shown altered activity in particular
increased activity in these causal
sub-junior regions there are 25 but it's
not always that causal it can be quite a
lot more anterior than that
also there have been both excited
inhibitory and excitatory changes
associated with these more rostral peri
genial regions path 332 and finally
they've been changes reported in
depressed subjects in the dorsal
anterior cingulate and in many of these
cases these changes seen in depression
are reversed following successful
treatment but not reversed
following unsuccessful treatment but
like I said before we have no idea
whether these changes are compensate or
your causal and also what symptom are
they responsible for so we in the first
incident have cannulated and targeted
area 25 and area 32 in the mama debt and
look to see if we activate or inactivate
these areas what are the effects on anta
dona and again we are looking to bridge
translational gaps in the study of
anhedonia because in a no genuine in
humans the primary measure is a
questionnaire to find out how anhedonia
core hedonic you're feeling you get off
the whole load of questions about your
state when you're experiencing various
rewards that's the measure in the clinic
in rodents the measure that's been used
a lot for doing translational studies is
sucrose consumption or sucrose
preference they ask the rat to choose
between a bottle of water and a bottle
of sucrose and as you might imagine rats
like soup roads
they show a strong preference to the
sucrose but in various anionic models
that preference decreases it's gone they
seem to drink water as much as sucrose
suggesting there and hedonic but there's
a big problem here because if you look
at depressed subjects many of them don't
have what you might call consump tree
anhedonia if you give them light wine or
you give them nice food they actually
think it's quite nice what seems to be
missing is either the ability to
anticipate the nice food or the nice
wine or the ability to work for it so
that's the gap but we know actually from
experimental studies in rodents and
primates that reward processing is far
more complicated than that and there are
anticipatory components to reward there
are these motivational components how
hard you prepare to work through Ward
and of course there can summitry compose
so when we're trying to study these in
meaningful looking at circuits we need
to be able to take into account the
different forms so in the marmoset so
far we've chosen a paradigm that allows
us to look at both an anticipatory and
consumer a SPECT of reward processing so
we're back to our simple Pavlovian
conditioning paradigm but this time
protective reward and so animals
presented with either a CS class such as
a sound a tone that after French
sections you get access to this big box
of your favorite food which is a box of
marshmallow or they get a CS presented
which is associated with an empty food
box and again they get a series of these
in the session and again we can look at
cardiovascular changes and behavioral
changes and just as I showed you for
their pets the negative conditioning
paradigm this time it's blood pressure
changes from baseline obviously at
baseline at zero if the stairs - is
presented which doesn't predict getting
access to food nothing happens where
this the CS plus is presented which the
animals learn predicts access to getting
act to the marshmallows it rises
and then it rises even more when they're
consuming the marshmallow and there's
also nice behavioral changes but for
what I should point out then here we
have in the one test both an
anticipatory phase and a con summitry
phase and then behaviorally anticipation
wise you can measure there again they're
kind of orienting head responses they
make to the CS that predicts getting
access to food but not v - which doesn't
predict food and consumer T wise you can
measure how much they consume of the
marshmallow when they get it and also
how long it takes them to actually start
eating it measures of consumer tree
arousal and so we did two manipulations
we first activated or inactivated the
area 32 which both of which have been
suggested to occur in certain forms of
depression
and there are no effects what this shows
you is either the blood pressure change
to the fifth gloss versus the stairs -
about five good strong cardiovascular
arousal response and that's our strong
card behavioral arousal response to the
stairs blast anticipation if we
inactivate area thirty-two using these
GABAergic agonists no effect they still
showed strong cardiovascular behavioral
effects in anticipation of reward if we
activate this region and we activated it
using a mixture of a gaba
b antagonist and an m' blue r23 agonist
which basically results in increasing
amount of glutamate that's released so
it makes the area more active this also
had no impact so the changes that we're
seeing in depression that may be either
reductions in activity region or
activations don't produce a basic effect
on either cancer can some tree or
anticipate a arousal but a very
different story emerges when we activate
over activate arrow 25 when we over
activate arrow 25 this again is our
cardiovascular arousal response to
anticipating reward but when we
inactivate this region when we apply
when we activate this region we make it
more active which is what has been
suggested very often you see in
depressed subjects we completely blunt
the cardiovascular arousal response and
we blunt it using two different methods
to cause overactivity the one I've
already described but the other one we
used i hydrant ID hydrocyanic acid which
is a and blocks the uptake of glutamate
in astrocytes so what it means is
there's more glutamate sloshing about
and whether there's more glutamate
sloshing about because you've blocked
the reuptake of it or there's more being
released
either way we blunt the reward
anticipate reals or responses so they
don't seem to be that bothered about
getting access to the food and the same
effect on the behavioral measure we
blunted however if you look at consumer
three measures both the cardiovascular
behavior of consumption measures they're
intact the animal eats as much he's as
quick to get the food he just doesn't
seem to show the excitement in
anticipation of it we've subsequently
this is just trying to show off we
finally got threads to work in the
mammal debt so I'm showing off that
we've used an excitatory dread which is
where threads are what are known as
designer sets of exclusively activated
by designer drugs and they are
engineered g-protein coupled receptor
that when activated by an otherwise
inert drug such as clozapine n-oxide CNO
actually activates these receptors these
designer receptors and in this case
we're using the HM 3dq receptor which is
excitatory so if you excite this
receptor you increase burst firing in
the area so it's yet another method of
over activating area 25 and when we use
this we get the exact same effects as we
got with the other two methods over
activating area 25 blunt ins the
anticipate reals or both cardiovascular
and behavioral at the three and four at
the six and ten mix for kiddos we don't
see it at the three but this fits in
with what we know about these dough
in other primate studies but
interestingly again no effect on
consumption so we replicated the effect
a third time using dreads
but we also being conscious of the fact
that we hadn't compared consumption in
the way they're doing that this new pros
preference test we've actually looked at
supers preference in the marma depths so
in the marmoset we also give them a
bottle of water and a bottle of sucrose
we let them choose which one they prefer
and they can spend up to an hour of two
hours
choosing between these two and normally
marmot it just like the rodents will
choose Duke Rhodes over the water
if you inactive so if you activate area
25 which Blount ins their anticipatory
arousal responses it has no effect on
their sucrose preference they appear to
be enjoying sucrose as much as any other
animal so they haven't got a consumptive
anhedonia
what we blocked is they are anticipatory
anhedonia they aren't anticipating
something nice anymore but to show that
our test is working in the moment that
given that we've never really done this
before we use naloxone which is an
opiate antagonist and show that in fact
it does block the effect so finally we
wanted to ask the question can we
reverse this and donek effect and we
chose to look at the effects of ketamine
so as I mentioned in the beginning
depression some patients do very well on
certain antidepressants such as the
SSRIs but some don't and the ones that
don't what we call the treatment
resistant subjects who don't seem to do
well on any of the typical
pharmacotherapies or behavioral
therapists and it's been shown that many
of these patients do seem to show quite
strong and Adhan ik deficits and they
seem to be particularly treatment
resistant to the SSRIs
but recently ketamine has been suggested
that it can actually act as a
antidepressant and have quite strong
effects quite quickly although as a
one-off dose they last only a sort of a
month or so
so ketamine may be effective at treating
some of these patients who don't respond
to SSRIs so we dissolve the question
does ketamine
any impact on our animals our Anna donek
effect produced by the overactivity
narrow 25 so this is the last body I
will show you we injected ketamine in
these same animals and then either for
hours afterwards or 1 day 7 days or 21
days we then injected dye hydroponic
acids so we over activated area 25 as
normal and of course is the overactive
8:25 expectancy of blunting as we
anticipate reals response we're looking
to see anhedonia but now we're asking
the question can we block that anatomic
effect by giving this single dose of
ketamine and the short answer was yes
ketamine has no impact on any of these
measures on its own but if we look at
the impact of dhk after this single dose
of ketamine at four hours after ketamine
the dhk the over activity of arrow 25
blunted the anticipate reals will
produce the Anna tonic effect however at
one day and seven days the dhk was no
longer able to produce the a node Annika
FEX but by three weeks afterwards it
produced it again so it appears that
ketamine does reverse the one of those
two ketamine does reverse this Anna
donek effect produced by the dye
hydronic acid but I'm going to leave it
there and I'm going to not show you the
last bodies so just to summarize then
what I've shown you today so far is that
area 25 what I didn't show you is some
of the imaging studies to implicate
these other two regions in this effect
seems to be quite important and when
over activated can produce appetitive
anhedonia anticipate rihanna dona
selectively for anticipation and not
consumption which means that this looks
fast similar to the anhedonia you see in
many depressed subjects and we've shown
you how ketamine can reverse this effect
what we obviously want to go on and do
is look to see whether SSRIs can also
reverse effect or not so we can begin to
start by setting out the neurochemical
modulation of the circuit
and likewise I've also shown you the
role of different parts of prefrontal
cortex in regulating downstream negative
emotional systems which can lead to
anxiety and again what we're currently
doing is looking to see whether ketamine
the glutamatergic antagonist or SSRIs
how selective they are for manipulating
or modulating these circuits and so
ultimately what we're hoping that's
going to be able to do is we're
beginning to fractionate out the
pathways that underlie different forms
of anxiety in different forms of
anhedonia which and by determining how
these are modulated by these distinct
neuro chemical systems we might be
getting one step closer to being ales
provide individualized treatment
strategies and I shall leave it there
and there to thank the colleagues in
particular dr. Hannah Clark and mr. lacy
Alexander who's done most of the
anhedonia work through the PhD student
in the lab thank you
[Applause]